[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boys we got tesh in the house
yeah
man what up what up thanks for having me
everybody so how are you doing what's
new
a lot a lot some big some uh big news we
got a movie
coming out on uh netflix
when did you film this uh we filmed this
outside of pittsburgh in a small town in
uh greensburg greensboro when did you
when did you oh when uh like two years
we did the whole festival circuit during
covid it's all digital it's been a long
long uh road but oh this one's like your
project not like you're just an actor
but this is i'm an actor and a producer
on it oh cool good [ __ ] dude so it's
called definition please it's gonna be
on netflix uh brought to us by the
wonderful people at array uh it's gonna
be out by the time this video is airing
so go on netflix now streaming it's
called definition please go support go
support go support so great south asians
um south asian story uh about a former
spelling bee champion
that never really leaves home it doesn't
amount to much she has to stay at home
take care of her sick mom her older
brother comes back and uh that's why
there's no spoilers let's just say [ __ ]
ensues
[ __ ] ensues it's a it's a nice nice
family dramedy oh is there like a that's
the title of the movie [ __ ] ensues
when i hear [ __ ] ensues i think of like
indian vin diesel comes out
there might be a scene where like in
diesel
in diesel shows up
he gets into a rickshaw
and he drives it
off the roof of the taj mahal
and he's flat in the air like that it
gets so high
we go to the moon yes
you should make a bollywood movie
this guy gets movie making man that's it
that's all you need just action when
does he say family
are you familiar
are you my family i can't even do it i
can't even do that
because like i'm thinking of him in my
ear oh man
he's just riding you know fast and the
furious would do really well with like a
cab driver from india because the the
traffic in india is [ __ ] horrendous
oh dude there's no rules that's a new
spin-off just a fast and furious you
could be the indian paul walker it would
be like slow and agitated that would be
that would be the indian equivalent that
was kind of like in uh rush hour three
when they're in paris france their
driver was just like a parisian driver
but i guess since he was so good like he
was taking jackie chan and uh chris
tucker around town what really yeah like
how often oh like off camera i was like
did they do this in the movie you're
talking in real life or in the movie oh
that's plants
like he was such a good driver
he is not real
right because then i'm thinking about
the dude from uh what is it uh deadpool
oh yeah
sorry
i was like i like that guy yeah that guy
sony what's up buddy if you see this hi
i love you
what so what does it mean to uh for in
terms of your specific role as a
producer on this one like what um so i i
uh slap some money on that [ __ ] like
producer baby not so much money no money
i didn't you know have money
no but more just sort of the active
responsibilities of of helping organize
things helping plan things post press
um
sort of sort of all of the business
stuff that goes
movie making was that different
difficult to like mix that while you're
creatively involved in it and also like
acting in it well when i'm there filming
i'm very much focused on the process of
filming you know so my job there on set
was to be the actor
and to play that role and make sure that
i'm fulfilling those duties so uh you
don't ever go like oh that's expensive
you know for me i wasn't wearing that
hat i'm sure other other people were
different producers yeah different
producers we had a great team um
sujata day who is the director writer
and stars in the movie so she wore many
hats um cameron fife wonderful producer
here in c sortie my old college buddy
that i ringed in um so we had we had a
great team of people at a june street
films and and added just productions and
then ava gibrane's company ray picked it
up and so we're bringing it to netflix
so we behind congrats man we've got a
really great team and i'm excited for
everyone to see it when you bring it to
netflix is it like cha-ching or not it
depends we're we're hoping you know oh
you don't know we'll find out after the
streams is that how they pay you uh no
there's a deal set in place but you know
i will
discuss that off cam
watch because that's why we signed
contracts
if you get if you get paid by stream you
guys [ __ ] watch it a million times
and just have it playing over and over
and over and over i just i just want to
say this to everyone out there you know
it very um it deals with a lot of topics
sort of in the in the south asian
culture and and asian culture abroad you
know there's a lot of
mental health issues that we bring up
and i think it'll be relatable to a lot
of families so please check it out if
you watch it we'll get more asian
content more south asian content i want
to see vince i want to see indies all
day yeah like don't you guys want to see
a fast and the furious [ __ ] yeah just
not false and the furious fast indian
fury fast indian furious
just with all asian people that'd be fun
there would just be arguments about who
could get the best deal at a car
dealership yeah
no you're not paying that much they're
just haggling the whole time the whole
movie is us haggling
and then still traveling on elephants
that'll be sick
dude the deal you should just do it
asian fast and furious it would just be
sponsored okay tokyo drift just have a
not white actor yeah yeah it'll be
you'll call it be called accident
that's it everyone's just crashing yeah
it'll be called accident
we have visors and gloves
get ready to go put on our wrists so
what's like during the filming that you
said it happened two years ago what's up
one just interesting story that happened
during filming
one interesting story
um
uh i'm trying to think it was such a
whirlwind
something that i really enjoyed was my
hotel was next to a sheets i don't know
if you guys know what that means what's
this
it's like a it's like a
super convenience store it's like a
7-eleven that's attached to a gas
station are you guys familiar with wawa
yeah okay so it's basically a massive
competitor to wawa oh but this and this
might be you know
unpopular opinion i've had both wawa and
sheets
and i gotta say sheets is pretty legit
where are sheets is it is it like an
east coast thing it's kind of but it's
not in new york
to like new jersey closer to
pennsylvania yeah and then i think
they're probably in like virginia and
the carolinas but it's it's like a fast
casual convenience store but you can get
pretty some some pretty dope sandwiches
which biscuits
schmisket that's like their version of
like a bacon and cheese on a biscuit
time are you really telling us one most
most interesting story you can think of
right now
let me [ __ ] tell you we shot the
movie in 14 days i was basically like oh
[ __ ]
out of hell she should have led with
that yeah yeah yeah that's the question
about the sandwiches right now
that was the most interesting i was like
oh my god i'm gonna get mozzarella
sticks i'm gonna have 14 different
dipping sauces i mean filming the movie
was amazing every day garlic
[ __ ] parmesan after working a 15-hour
day 18 hours what you want to do is eat
i just want to eat every day was like 15
to 18 hours it was i would say 12 to 15
hours it wasn't like look we had the
greatest time i had the greatest time
yeah uh the crew took care of me casa
crew took care of me had great scene
partners great producing partners great
director um
except kunal but yeah [ __ ] no
but we i know and i are in the indian
actor universe metaverse because it met
a verse because you know you haven't
seen kanalan shank cheese in there
uh but he was in another movie that i
was in called hot mess holiday
which was on comedy central and he plays
a spelling bee champion in that movie
and in this movie definition please he
plays
a spelling bee i don't well he's not a
champion because he loses oh
to our main character monica but he's a
spelling bee contender so we i have this
running joke with him that him and i are
intrinsically connected is that a trope
in the indian community about spelling
bees does everyone do it i don't know
like the last 80 spelling bee champions
have been indian there was like oh when
we were filming the movie two years ago
i believe there was an eight-way tie
seven of the contestants were indian and
this the eighth contestant was just like
a small white jewish girl wow
that's pretty dominant pretty dude the
spelling bees are like nba dominant you
know like we dominated who started it
like what got indians to go like this is
my [ __ ]
i don't know some auntie some uncle
they're like you can't run you can't
jump but you can spell
there's physics engineer like you guys
smash so many of those things
i think things that are uh repetitive
that we that can be learned through
repetition
that's why i think a lot of south asians
and you know asians in general are good
at individual
you know sports where we focus on that
go play tennis learn the piano the
individual sport of being a tech ceo
yeah exactly
that's that's the greatest yeah we're
dominating because when you're a tech
ceo you're alone at the top taking money
from everybody
tough job
damn so who's the character that you
play in this movie i play uh the brother
the brother that comes home
uh it's our father's one-year death
anniversary
and so
it's a kind of a reunion between the mom
and the brother and sister this starts
off a little bit sad with some heavy it
starts off
real yeah it's real it's real it's real
wholesome yeah and uh you know there's
there's some skeletons in the closet
that they have to confront i don't want
to give away any spoilers so that's the
juicy part yeah check it out check it
out we're getting good reviews today's
video is brought to you by bombass
mission it's pretty simple make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an equal item donated
when you buy bombas you are also giving
to someone in need bon bons designed
their socks underwears and shirts to be
so comfortable that you can't wait to
put on every single day everything they
make is soft seamless tagless and has a
luxuriously cozy feel they're made from
super soft materials like merino wool
pima cotton and even cashmere which
makes them perfect for cozy winter
layers there's a pair of bomb butt socks
for everything you do really they come
in tons of options like comfy
performance styles for every sport and
activity that keeps you moving bomba
t-shirts are made with thoughtful design
features like invisible seams soft
fabrics and just the right weight so it
hangs bumbus underwear has this like
barely there feel
with second skin support that make you
even forget that they're even there
that's good but in a good way
and did you know that socks underwear
and t-shirts are the number one most
requested items at a homeless shelter
that's why bone bust donates one item
for every item sold so far bomba's
customers like you has helped donate
over 50 million essential items of
clothing so if you want some super
comfortable clothes
and you want to help out a good cause go
to bonebox.com off the record to get 20
off any purchase that's b o m b a s dot
com slash off the record to get 20 off
any purchase boombox.com off the record
we got good reviews we got a new york
times view come out today oh
yeah awesome
we're really excited so so far as as
per at the time filming this video we
have a hundred percent on rotten
tomatoes if that matters to anyone out
there that's a big deal that's a big
that matters to me when i pick movies
yeah
you get 80 of raw tomatoes that's like
wow i i always love it when our friends
become successful but i also don't
because they don't come back on the show
because they're publicist their
publicist goes it's too dangerous to be
on just kidding news don't [ __ ] get
back on that i mean
he's been successful for a while he's
here thank you but but he's not like
he's not like shane she's successful
like canal you know what i mean like not
canal you know to me like canal
it's shakesy where he doesn't say a
single word have you gotten kona on the
show he's i like this everything
he doesn't want to do it he's got love
he's like i'm too funny for the show
no he's great i love him i should reach
out to him actually
most of it is because people get busy or
like you guys have history you guys all
went to college yeah he's all me
and i met canal through lawrence
lawrence cow because they were roommates
do you know what lawrence goes i don't
think lawrence cowan's uh plays tommy
juan wu assassins little asian dude um
and but they had a uh they were yeah
they had a um a place in k-town together
for a while yeah yeah okay cool well
we're all connected that's since he
doesn't know lauren is setting up that
one
we just move out it doesn't matter but
anyways we're all in the movie uh when
you when you become like [ __ ] a-list
a-list a-list
he's like i'm gonna i'm gonna kidnap you
and hold you ransom
alice aylas aylas right see that one
thing you just look like you're gonna
shove that in my ass oh that's a musical
there's no batteries but then
oh that's cute and it speaks i like it
it's so joe it's ridiculous so
um will you still show up on the show
i'm gonna hold you i'm gonna [ __ ]
hold you to it yeah man all right cool
he's got a little ptsd on people kind of
i know like
everyone just leaves us and never comes
back we should do we should do we should
do a show at vegas we should just do it
like you know in the casino in the
middle of the floor maybe the trump
tower yeah maybe will they be able to
handle with you in the lobby of the
trump towers the lobby
they have great chandeliers so you
filmed that about two years ago yeah
yeah and it's finally coming out now
finally so what have you worked on
recently or about to work on that maybe
will come out later is there any
anything any project in the podcast
chiang chi 2. uh i'm right now i'm just
writing developing stuff looking looking
to pitch to networks um we've got some
new barbie stuff coming down the
pipeline uh i don't have dates on those
but yeah we recorded them
if you could give a little bit of juice
a little bit me on something that you're
like kind of you know creatively
bubbling around in your own mind you
know like writing producing like you
just said give us a little taste uh yeah
so i've got i've got two two shows that
i'm working on right now one is a
family drama that takes place in
malaysia
and we say shows are you mentally and
intentionally like episodically creative
yeah this one this one is episodic and
then another one i'm developing with one
of my very close friends um
is about
uh
kind of our experiences growing up with
each other and um
it's about this this
gay kid who burns down his apartment and
he has to move back in with his with his
helicopter mom your friend burnt out the
apartment that that's
that's uh we made that part
but the game you know the only best part
only the best
of familiar gameplay
and yeah
because if you have a gay homie and he's
hitting on you
how do you deal with that just take it
as a compliment
take it on the chin you know yeah but
then that's kind of like
don't drink too much together that's
kind of like how if you have a platonic
friendship with a girl and then she's
like really into you but you're not
really into her and it's like how do you
say no but then still stay friends and
then they're not really lying just to
simp for you i feel like you've had this
problem happen you so many times you're
speaking from a deep deep rooted
experience i had to end the friendship
yeah i bet you everyone can relate to
that yeah a chick like a chick that's
real yeah just just having like
in your entire life being really close
to like you know a friend of the
opposite sex and then like having
some sort of uh gray area yeah you know
i had an accidental one
that i was like turned into geo right
that was one and i'm here
this one tripped me out because you know
i just like the [ __ ] around
so i had one of my tight friends in high
school
i don't know why but i thought it would
be funny if i
uh
broke it to her that i'm actually in
love with her yo and then
so i started talking about it and she
goes no really i'm like yeah i'm like
i've been hiding these feelings for so
long it's funny dude how could you
how could you go and i kept going and
then she was like i don't know it's
gonna change so many things in a friend
dynamic i'm like i know i just have to
get on my chest
oh my god this is crazy
but i can't see us working out i'm like
oh you're disgusting what the [ __ ] and
then i spit
you spit on her face
this is doing like you know like in high
school in our in our days it's
you could be on the phone for hours yeah
of course because that's all you really
had there you were on the phone until
you your parents picked it up and
[ __ ] yelled at you yeah yeah pretty
much and then i got the feelings to come
out the other way and i was like oh [ __ ]
i think i [ __ ] up you guys could she
realize she liked you yeah she said she
could see a future together and then i
was like
oh oh
oh man
wait how do you put the like
like the candy back in the pinata you
know i'm like
you can't do that bro it all came out i
don't know if you see pinatas after they
released their i didn't put the scene
back in the [ __ ] chat bro like what
do you support girls the pinata did you
ever did the friendship ever recover or
was that it
actually she's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
but it was just it recovered but
somewhere inside something died yeah
she's gonna come kill you one day you
scarred her dude i know maybe that's
[ __ ] up dude it's pretty funny though
an [ __ ] but we're friends so it's
okay but if you know bart you're like
that is the most bark thing to do that's
true just to [ __ ] around like no real
point the most part is when he goes
he's like this at home on the phone oh
no bart messed up he just put it on mute
you know he's like
he's like tying it around like you know
because he had he does the whole static
thing oh no go through a tunnel what did
you hope would happen yeah exactly so
like
i'm [ __ ] around too i don't know i
think i'm just talking and having a good
time and then i was like what if she
just what if she was like nah dude
you're gross
like what if she was like no [ __ ] way
like you're disgusting i think it would
have been easier
that might have been easier and i think
i had the upper hand in the conversation
because i knew i'm [ __ ] around so if
it backfired it's like oh oh yeah like i
was joking or maybe you grow up now and
you actually realize maybe
you did like her yeah maybe that was the
level of your life
maybe being able to joke around that
comfortably with somebody subconscious
this is this is how you express your
love hey shout out name last name
give us our social security number i
feel like bart would propose marriage
just to get a reaction and see what
happens
and then be like
oh
you really thought this was real he's
not putting it on the roof oh
[ __ ] dude i ate like 90 boxes of cracker
jacks honestly i probably would and
because like these big events to me are
like more jokey i never propose to geo
because the real [ __ ] i don't do the
it's almost the opposite in my brain so
how did you ask her to we didn't we just
started planning it you just you just
put her like you're just like you're
coming with me we just started planning
it get in the car planned it we didn't
even have a ring we didn't have like i
didn't put anything on her finger or
anything we bought the ring like a year
or two after we got similarly a part of
her inside died i know found out later
we'll plan we'll plan it we're playing a
secret proposal
to me
show her your romantic side i know i'm a
[ __ ] head i don't know you gotta run by
ryan or joe or something dude i could
run by joe but he's probably gonna be
down with whatever idea i have yeah you
should always run it by joe though i do
think
or or joe just adds more flair to it and
then it becomes even crazier you should
do two versions your version and the
version that's given by you yeah you
just take it from the top
yeah we're gonna put both of these on
youtube we'll see which one people like
better
and we'll just stick with that story
i'm pretty romantic
out of the two
out of both of you guys i think joe
might be more what's the most romantic
thing you've done you might have pretty
much [ __ ] put semen in his mouth
[Laughter]
that's good [ __ ] ate her [ __ ] in las
vegas bro
that was it in vegas
circus circus it was special
in the trump casino it was at the trump
tower
[Music]
you